euromaxx highlights and here's your host
guy instead greetings from the German
capital and welcome to our highlights
from the past week which this time
around happened to include the following
story digital drawing Spaniard Sergio
Albia creates portraits using computer
data trivia test why Germans love to
play the game app miss do n and
sculpture central Berlin company creates
giant monuments for artists well in the
wake of the recent NSA scandals concerns
have been rife regarding personalized
and computer traffic information being
collected around the world in fact one
of the big themes at the world's biggest
trade fair for information technology
that was that sabot in Hanover just last
week was big data and how to handle it
but for some artists at least big data
can also spell a big bonus and we went
to Barcelona to see why these portraits
of real people all have one thing in
common they reveal more than just a face
they're a collage of that individual's
personal data the faces have been
generated by computer programs written
by a Spanish artist what I mean for me
the computer is the same as a brush when
you paint a picture critics don't say
you didn't paint the picture the brush
do is the same thing my writer program
and the program is a tool that creates
the picture como Araminta genera una una
hora the program generates a portrait by
simulating Savio RBX brushwork as it
combines digital information about a
person with the person's image ibf makes
final adjustments by hand Camilla
Faustina Fiona's que ahora cual quiere
lemon the fascinating thing for me is to
integrate information that has until now
been ignored by the art world such as a
person's heart beat and turn that into
arch the possibilities are amazing lapis
UTIs passing under for his Stardust
project I be at came up with a software
process that generates portraits in the
form of collages of images from the
Hubble Space Telescope content is Queen
combines internet videos to construct an
image of Queen Elizabeth the second
and another project mixed real-time data
about a person's driving style such as
speed and fuel consumption with an image
of that person's face the eclectic
approach comes naturally to
barcelona-based 45 year old I jack in
2009 he decided to make a living by
combining his previous career as a
computer programmer with his art studies
before con thing I love working with
technology is incredibly creative
writing a program is the same as writing
poetry or drawing a portrait programming
is about finding solutions and in doing
so you're being very creative we met
sirvio Antioch as he was testing his new
smartphone app with a friend it can send
your picture and your personal data to
the artist who generates a unique
portrait it all begins with a selfie
the program can collect pulse rate voice
samples and much more aplicación kappa
the app captures a person's life
experiences for example it record sounds
or words from conversations and of
course video where the guitar video RBX
idea is to use all that information to
synthesize an image of a special day or
journey and reflect a certain amount of
connected personal data people leave
clear data trails across the internet
even if they're unaware they're doing so
their locations their activities on
social networks everyone amasses large
amounts of personalized data more and
more artists are seizing on this data as
a source of creativity jose luis de
Vicente is a specialist in digital
culture art and technology or in the
others can plug in our discs for
exploring collective emotions trying to
understand how we all feel in one
particular instant they want to
understand how so many individuals
interact online and collectively create
greater movements with other artists are
using the data to shed light on a world
that's out there and in many ways is
incomprehensible to us eco muchas
gracias esta cuidando in 2012 Italian
artist power-law cheerio analyzed photos
from google street view he then pasted
life-size images of people onto the
spots where they'd been caught unaware
and without permission by google's
cameras
in 2013 German artist Catalina's evading
combined a hundred thousand images
collected by the u.s. space agency NASA
to digitally project a blue Sun what
looked like microscopic images are in
fact a 3d visualization of a computer
virus by Romanian artist Alex dragula
school his latest project analyzes
online communities to create maps of
social network behavior meanwhile Savio
biack is generating a program from data
gleaned by his appt the speed and detail
of the brushwork are influenced by
real-life data input such as pulse rate
lavish onboard complicating my vision is
to turn this project into a completely
autonomous system that can create art
long after I'm gone when the Yu Yan
estate right now though serrio a black
sometimes still has to rely on the
analog world especially when it comes to
enjoying his art on paper and when
they're not worrying who might be
getting hold of their personal data the
digital generation spends much of its
time playing quiz apps now one of the
most popular is Chris do L or quiz clash
in English and designed for smartphones
or tablets it's already available in 13
countries and has been downloaded
millions of times the app was developed
by a trio from Sweden and as its
popularity rages on here in Germany
quite literally we thought we'd find out
why Germans are so obsessed with the
quiz show format
this is one app that gets people going
quiz jewel is a social trivia game that
you can play with one other person or
with a group now a Hamburg ad agency has
launched Germany's first championship
they're looking to crown Germany's
cleverest ad agency so now people are
even playing at work in design firm guns
on the heads on outside it's an
entertaining way to pass the time you
test your knowledge and learn a bit
along the way I think it's delightful
not even come on it's fun it's exciting
and even addictive it's fun to see if
you know more than your friends Mia bias
as an appointment as if you know that
I'm one of the top two million players
number 1 million nine hundred and twelve
thousand seven hundred and eighty-two to
be precise that's my fat sister not bad
when you consider that there are about
six million active players in Germany
getting started is easy just download
the app and find an opponent each round
has three categories and there are 21
categories in all for every question
there are four possible answers but the
clock is ticking so you have to think
fast in the end the person with the most
correct answers wins
now over to Stockholm Sweden where the
apps inventors all live there around 30
years old and have been friends since
they were children
Robert fisted Carla Landon and his
brother Allah are all fans of social
games and also enjoy computer
programming the app is no flash in the
pan the developers spent two years
trying out successful smartphone games
and then set to work on their own it was
in 2011 there was a really popular
social game and that was based on the
scrabble principle a word game and we
realized the strength in that kind of
social game and we wanted to do a
similar game but with our own twist so
that's when we came up with idea of a
quiz game like that two weeks after
release the app was already the most
popular download in Sweden the tiny
startup is meanwhile a mid-sized company
with about 50 staff from across Europe
the staff member from Russia designs new
graphic elements that can be used to
create online identities the game has
been released in 13 countries every day
they add hundreds of new trivia
questions they all have to be translated
and adapted for each country that can be
tricky we had an example in Germany what
this trocadero and this is a question
that had been transferred from the
Swedish database and the person who
translated it probably thought that yeah
it's fine it's it would work in Germany
also but the correct answer was a soft
drink and that soft drink had apparently
never been launched in Germany so no one
know what it was everyone guessed that
it was a tropical island quiz games have
been popular for years the Trivial
Pursuit board game was first launched in
Canada in the 1980s and went on to sell
more than 90 million times around the
world in the digital age mini trivia
games have gone online there are more
than 2,000 available in app stores but
quiz jewel has by far the most fans it's
been downloaded about 23 million times
around the world its biggest fan base is
in Germany where it's been downloaded 14
million times elvis assigned a super
story i think there's something very
German about wanting to test your mettle
in games like this in quiz duel and you
have to rely on your knowledge and skill
like that gets you social status here
under the end by my few Germans like to
be knowledgeable and they like to
demonstrate that so trivia games like
this are perfect for us epic diamond
back in the Hamburg ad agency the
Germany white jewel has gone to the next
round by the end of March the smartest
ad agency will be crowned and soon there
will even be a quiz jewel on German
television with competitors in the
studio taking on viewers at home well
they say that anything is possible when
it comes to art or at least almost
anything and when an artist's idea is
for some reason bigger than the studio
space that he has to work with while
that is where sculpture Berlin comes
into play their oversized workshop is
renowned for taking on these massive
kinds of tasks and the three owners have
already saved the day for a number of
projects here's more a sculpture nearing
completion the employees of sculpture
Berlin have worked on this monumental
artwork made of styrofoam and plastic
for the past seven months today it's
getting the finishing touches Christian
Meier is one of the owners of the Berlin
studio it specializes in turning artists
ideas into three-dimensional reality
we've got from Florence idea there
centuries companies have simply turned
artists visions into reality the
exciting thing for us has always been
the challenge of bringing a bow to work
for it and this size is a very special
challenge because the whole thing is
just huge following less FF easy is the
sculpture is 8 meters long and just
under 6 meters high to start with there
was just a miniature model designed by
the German artist Haemon Tacoma
sculpture Berlin made a 3d scan of it
and then implemented it on a scale of 10
to 1 the photo League Donna see the
advantages that I don't have to
permanently hire 10 to 15 say both of
the Lord the feminine styling was the
decision that side did so that when the
piece is being worked on I can turn my
attention to other projects right
possession Cotton's christian meier and
his two colleagues feeling boy muller
and dominique bednarik founded sculpture
berlin in 2006 all three studied
sculpture but now they see themselves as
service providers who can advise other
artists on which techniques and
materials to select
oft Moosman I've done often you have to
figure out what is doable it's not
always possible to give artists
everything they want there's a process
of convergence in which you look for a
solution that comes as close as possible
to the artists idea what seems in this
one's bosepandi them somehow the works
that are exhibited are also our works
but for us it's enough to know that we
did it our name doesn't have to be on it
looks like mr. hey dusty it had a noble
hostage can sustain yeah this is not the
head also the room it's a great
challenge we encounter artistic projects
our task is very rich in content tivo in
ugly and it's just nice to be a part of
it tournament efficiency design my
father's sculpture Berlin has already
built several hundred works including
creations by internationally renowned
artists such as the German Andreas Hofer
Natalie joburg from Sweden and Icelandic
singer and artist Bureau Catalina horses
a regular customer she's one of
Germany's most renowned painters but
when she wants to express herself
through sculpture she relies on advice
from sculpture Berlin this is where
sculpture Berlin have the advantage
because they studied out themselves and
know the problems you face when you
don't know one hundred percent how it
should look but you have a very good
idea of the methods that should be used
to make it
I want commas sculpture has already been
through this process it now faces a
journey of 600 kilometers from Berlin to
the city of Claver on the Dutch border
but it's all cashed in so I target on
with it'll take a couple of days to set
it off the base has to be completed
should we have to put down gravel and
Roger by side and then the artwork we
finish it's the same for many other
artists they lack the space and
expertise to produce such large-scale
works in their own studios the three
experts from sculpture Berlin can help
them and are there to celebrate when the
artwork is finished I don't feel I can
breathe easily until the sculpture is
gone but it's a good feeling that it's
finally on the truck now of info it
won't be long before the three are back
at work again their next assignment is
another giant sculpture
and now for a breath of fresh air were
headed to the region around the chateaus
mountains in southeastern France that's
the home of the famous liquor of the
same name and not that far from gonna
blush am showed is that area's highest
summit well tourism agriculture and
forestry are vital industries here
making it a terrific place for an
outdoor holiday at just about any time
of year and it also has the added bonus
of french country cuisine wherever you
go rising more than 2,000 metres above
sea level the Sham showed is the highest
peak in the chateaus range visitors come
from all over the world to enjoy the
beauty of the region many stay at brunel
Charles's converted barn the village of
lissa Pietro's has a cultural trail that
begins at the nine hundred year old
church tamiya montagnana in this
mountainous region perhaps the remnants
of the past are easier to see because
mountain people don't move around as
much histoire fakin is all languages
they stay attached to their identity and
traditions and they like to share them
with visitors Vito winter sports
enthusiast seeking a less strenuous
holiday prefer shadows to even the alps
and visitors to the National Park can
get an authentic taste of french country
life
this cultural trail leads curious
visitors through the countryside into
the past this grain Depot is more than
500 years old but also the construction
is quite special it's completely made of
wood with interlocking pieces of timber
like this this is fasola the sort of
construction is quite typical for this
region and alpine valleys a also closed
the regional government has implemented
strict nature protection laws to make
tourism as sustainable as possible while
maintaining the area's natural beauty
sitting on top or the mountains here are
more gentle than the central Alps or the
moment you can see in the colors the
shapes and the lines I love living in a
sharp loose because I was born here
vball my family and my ancestors were
here before me laughs I meet them is all
set for it Allah Allah the most famous
cultural heritage site in shirt rose is
well hidden in its mountains the head
monastery of the curfews ian order
founded in 1080 for about 50,000
visitors are drawn here every year but
none are permitted to actually visit the
monastery the monks prefer that their
contemplation remain undisturbed instead
a nearby museum tells their story you
know bottles the order has always been
very limited in size but it's
philosophical and spiritual importance
for Christianity as a whole has been
enormous throughout its history many
famous people such as jean-jacques
rousseau have come to seek inspiration
from the everyday lives and the
spirituality of the people here dim one
even today many people still come to
find out more about what goes on behind
these walls she so kids the bus there is
a real the monastery walls hold many
secrets such as the 300 year old recipe
for this green look yer shadows also
lends its name to the mixture of 130
herbs
mars and flowers that go into the drink
the distillery in nearby bar is open to
the public so the modern you click
complex it really is a very complex
liquor it's currently quite fashionable
with barman and cocktail mixers they
know lots of ways to use it they add
other Lee curves or fruit juices and
they make marvelous cocktails maybe you
cook then at the end of each tour
visitors can taste a sample after all
it's often said that shirt rose has
medicinal properties
well last week in Frankfurt the
international music fair opened its
doors and we took that as our cue to
train the spotlight on a German piano
manufacturer Bestine pianos have been
around since the year 1853 and the
company based right here in Berlin but
also in rural Saxony is Europe's largest
producer of uprights and grand pianos
well they also export them all over the
globe and so we went to see how they
resonate internationally at one time
Besh Stein was among the world's leading
instrument manufacturers but then it
lost much of its shine in the past few
years though besh Stein regained some of
its former prestige
Georgian pianist dude animus Manish Vili
is paying a visit to the best teen
center in Berlin she had her debut at
new york city's carnegie hall in 2006
she's been a fan of betadine grand
pianos since her student days to assist
they're torn it's round it's the bel
canto sound which you rarely hear
anymore oh I played many best ines and
always for the same reason first and
foremost a piano has to sing it can't be
a percussion instrument it has to be an
instrument that sings woman sending in
this installment pianist and composer
Franz Liszt played on instruments by
bechstein in the 19th century this one
was delivered to him in 1862
fone de yong a hundred years ago
bechstein was selling about 5,000
instruments a year today it's about the
same number there were slumps and high
points in between Carl Bosch Stein
founded the company in Berlin in 1853
betadine had its headquarters and
workshops in Berlin later they also
opened a production site in London the
instrument soon gained an international
reputation nebosh Dean has its
headquarters in the steel vac design and
office center in Berlin
but both the upright and the grand
pianos are built in the small town of
South hennas Dorf in the eastern state
of saxony a grand piano takes a full
year and about 500 hours to make
the heart of the instrument is the
soundboard it occupies the space in the
middle of the grand piano and amplifies
the vibrations of the strings yahaya
divas nun spoon Allah this is where we
dry the soundboards of all the best ein
concert pianist Nikita Genesis we use
only Italian spruce wood because it's
the best wood for our concert pianos
one's look once happens fomenting I
noticed during the manufacturing process
each piano is given a thorough
going-over by a machine that plays up to
50,000 keystrokes in 20 minutes the
final touches are provided by master
craftsman Matthias cleansing do Steve a
vital part of my job is adjusting the
Hammers he about of the lava and I was
just doing that no but if I had to try
to express it in numbers well I'd say
that determines about forty percent of
the sound of a grand pianos visa langu
fuga I'm in the clink
French music professor and Conda man has
come to purchase instruments for her
conservatory she says she's very
impressed citroen distal it's a question
of the balance between the sound and the
keys where I sit and these create the
best equilibrium between the quality of
the sound and the quality of the key
action lakai needed to see a veg tine
grand once had the same reputation as a
Stradivari violin here in Berlin they're
hoping to regain that lofty praise from
pianists around the world well that is
all we have time for this time so thanks
for watching and until we meet again
Alice coup to oust baleen take good care
on toffee dozen just
you